Founder Office: Ja.
Founder Office: Hallo, Guten Abend Alle zusammen, Die, die
Founder Office: die 1.
Suresh: Guten Abend.
Founder Office: Die.
Chathura Praboda: nein.
Founder Office: Die die die ist, die, die mit maximal 2 4 Teilnehmerinnen und 2.
Founder Office: Sie stellen Fragen und Antworten auf Fragen Eduard, die
Founder Office: Sie bitten, um etwas und Antworten auf Bitten.
Founder Office: In Teil 1 können Sie 3 Punkte bekommen.
Founder Office: In Teil 2 gibt es 6 Punkte insgesamt 15 Punkte.
Founder Office: die die ist die, die die ist, und stellen sich vor das Gespräch ist kurz.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Founder Office: Die die Prüferin sagt.
Founder Office: Bitte erzählen Sie uns ein bisschen.
Founder Office: Wer sind sie?
Founder Office: Hier sind einige Worte zur Hilfe.
Founder Office: Name.
Chathura Praboda: Ihr alter Name.
Chathura Praboda: Frauen, Beruf, Hobby.
Founder Office: Okay, Name, alter Land.
Founder Office: Die.
Founder Office: Die die.
Founder Office: Okay, Stuttgart.
Founder Office: Ja, wir möchten beginnen.
Founder Office: Ja, wer möchte beginnen?
Founder Office: Beginnen Sie bitte.
Chathura Praboda: Ich.
Chathura Praboda: Ich komme aus Sri Lanka. Ich wohne in Gol. Ich.
Founder Office: Okay.
Chathura Praboda: Ich berufe.
Founder Office: Ich arbeite nicht.
Chathura Praboda: Man weiß.
Founder Office: Okay.
Chathura Praboda: Mein Hobby ist Billard zu.
Founder Office: Ja. Mein Hobby ist.
Chathura Praboda: Ein Fußballspiel.
Founder Office: Fußball spielen. Okay, Sehr gut.
Founder Office: und.
Chathura Praboda: Ich bin 24 Jahre alt.
Chathura Praboda: Ich komme aus Sri Lanka.
Founder Office: Nun gut.
Chathura Praboda: Ich wohne in Kohl.
Founder Office: Ich wohne in Gold.
Chathura Praboda: Deutsch.
Founder Office: Deutsch und ein bisschen Deutsch.
Founder Office: Ich arbeite nicht.
Chathura Praboda: Ich.
Founder Office: Arbeite nicht.
Founder Office: Ich bin Student.
Chathura Praboda: Okay.
Founder Office: Ich arbeite nicht. Ich bin Student.
Chathura Praboda: Mein Hobby ist Fußballspieler.
Founder Office: Ist.
Founder Office: Ja.
Founder Office: Haben Sie ein Handy?
Founder Office: Ja, ich habe ein Handy. Ja, ich habe ein Handy.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Founder Office: Haben Sie ein Handy?
Founder Office: Haben Sie ein Handy? Ja, ich habe ein Handy. Okay, ja. Ich habe ein Handy.
Founder Office: Wie ist Ihre Handynummer.
Founder Office: Wie ist ja Handynummer.
Chathura Praboda: Das.
Founder Office: Ja.
Chathura Praboda: Nein.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Founder Office: Die.
Chathura Praboda: und.
Founder Office: und.
Chathura Praboda: Rede.
Founder Office: Meine Handynummer ist die: Wie ist ihr Vorname?
Chathura Praboda: Mein Vorname ist.
Founder Office: Okay. Bitte buchstabieren Sie Ihren Vornamen.
Founder Office: Bitte buchstabieren Sie Ihren Vornamen.
Chathura Praboda: die.
Founder Office: Die.
Chathura Praboda: Am Manifest. Nehmen wir.
Founder Office: Ja.
Chathura Praboda: A.
Founder Office: Sie.
Chathura Praboda: H.
Chathura Praboda: A.
Founder Office: Ja.
Chathura Praboda: Haben.
Chathura Praboda: A. U. A.
Founder Office: O r, O.
Chathura Praboda: R a.
Founder Office: Ja, und.
Suresh: Ja.
Suresh: mein Name ist Suresha drange. Ich bin 39 Jahre alt, Ich komme aus in Sri Lanka und wo in Columbo. Ich kann sprechen. Single ich Englisch und Deutsch. Ich bin Arbeiter in Columbo.
Suresh: In meiner Freizeit höre ich Musik.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Ein.
Suresh: Vielen Dank.
Suresh: Ich bin 39, Jahre alt.
Founder Office: Okay, ich bin ein 30 Jahre alt.
Suresh: Ich komme aus in Sri Lanka und.
Founder Office: Ich komme aus Sri Lanka. Okay.
Founder Office: ja, ich komme aus Sri Lanka und wohne in Columbo.
Suresh: Ich kann sprechen, Singlisch, Englisch und Deutsch.
Founder Office: Gut.
Founder Office: Ja, ich kann gut, signalisisch, Englisch und ein bisschen Deutsch sprechen, aber gut.
Suresh: Amen.
Founder Office: Okay, zentralesisch.
Suresh: Gut.
Founder Office: Ich kann gut Singhalesisch, Englisch.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: und einbitzen. Deutsch.
Suresh: Eigentlich.
Founder Office: Deutsch.
Suresh: und.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Zeit.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: Gerne.
Suresh: Ich bin in Colombo.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: technischen.
Founder Office: Ja, Hä.
Suresh: Deswegen.
Founder Office: Die die.
Suresh: Auch technische, ja.
Founder Office: Techniker.
Suresh: Das.
Founder Office: Ich bin Techniker von Beruf und arbeite in Colombo.
Suresh: Der Schnicker.
Founder Office: Ich nicke und arbeite in Colombo.
Founder Office: Ich bin Techniker und arbeite in Colombo.
Suresh: In meiner Freizeit hole Ich musik.
Founder Office: Ja gut.
Founder Office: In meiner Freizeit.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: Das höre ich.
Suresh: Höre ich Musik.
Founder Office: Sehr gut.
Founder Office: In meiner Freizeit höre ich Musik.
Founder Office: Die ist.
Founder Office: Wie ist Ihre Hausnummer.
Suresh: Ist.
Suresh: Hausnummer ist die.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Aber.
Founder Office: Hausnummer.
Suresh: Andere.
Founder Office: und.
Suresh: Meine Heilung.
Suresh: Ist, ist 250.
Founder Office: Hausnummer, Handynummer, Telefonnummer.
Suresh: Ein.
Founder Office: Nehmen.
Founder Office: Die ist.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Meine Hausnummer: Handynummer, Telefonnummer, Autonummer, Postleitzahl, Ausleitzahl, die.
Suresh: Die,
Founder Office: Wir.
Suresh: Ich.
Founder Office: Ja.
Suresh: und nein.
Founder Office: Wir.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: und.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Der.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: 0. 0, 3. 0. 0. Ja. 1, 2. Mal. 0, 2. Mal. 0.
Suresh: So.
Founder Office: Die.
Founder Office: Die und die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Mein Name ist Guantan Dwandare. Ich bin 23 Jahre alt.
Founder Office: 23 Jahre alt.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ich komme aus Sri Lanka.
Founder Office: Ich komme aus Sri Lanka.
Founder Office: Die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: In.
Founder Office: Okay.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ich spreche Singlisch, Englisch, unein, Deutsch.
Founder Office: Gut.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ich bin alte Projektmanager von Beruf.
Founder Office: Aha, Okay.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Meine.
Founder Office: und.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Mein Hobby ist Computer. Ich spiele Spiele.
Founder Office: Ja, meine Hobbys Computerspiele spielen? Gut, Ja.
Founder Office: wie ist Ihre Postleitzahl.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Meine ausbleibt?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ja.
Founder Office: Meine Postleitzahl ist.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Meine Postleitzahl ist Swing.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: 4 Hunde.
Founder Office: Meine Postleitzahl ist okay. Gut.
Founder Office: wie ist Ihr Familienname Run?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Zweifamilienname ist en u.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: W. A. N.
Founder Office: Die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Nur.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: A.
Founder Office: Die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Wandern.
Founder Office: Die B.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: B, A, N.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: D, E.
Founder Office: A.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: D A, R, R, A.
Suresh: Ich komme aus Sri Lanka.
Founder Office: Ja. Okay, bitte buchstabieren Sie. Sri Lanka ist.
Suresh: Es Ja.
Suresh: S: A: S, A, H.
Founder Office: Hin.
Suresh: L, a, n, K,
Founder Office: Ja ist die, die ich
Founder Office: die die beantworten Sie die folgenden Fragen. Schriftlich. Bei der Vorstellung, die Stichwörter, Name, alte Land, Wohnungsprachen, Beruf, Hobby.
Founder Office: Wie alt sind Sie bei sich Wo wohnen Sie?
Founder Office: Wie heißt die Straße?
Founder Office: Wie ist ihre Hausnummer.
Founder Office: Wie ist Ihre Hausnummer?
Founder Office: Wie ist die Postleitzahl?
Founder Office: Haben Sie Telefon: Wie ist Ihre Nummer? Haben Sie Telefon: Wie ist Ihre Nummer
Founder Office: haben Sie ein Handy? Wie ist Ihre Nummer, Welche Sprachen sprechen Sie?
Founder Office: Was ist Ihre Muttersprache? Was ist Ihre Muttersprache?
Founder Office: Was sind Sie von Beruf? Was sind sie von Beruf?
Founder Office: Haben Sie Kinder? Ja, was ist ihr Hobby? Was machen Sie gern?
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Ich.
Suresh: Ich.
Founder Office: Die ich bin, genau direkt.
Suresh: und.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Gut.
Founder Office: Ich bin von Beruf.
Founder Office: Mein Beruf ist okay.
Founder Office: Das Gespräch ist kurz, was können Sie sagen?
Founder Office: Ich
Founder Office: Ich buchstabiere meinen Vornamen, Ich buchstabieren.
Chathura Praboda: Meine.
Founder Office: Sind.
Chathura Praboda: Zweiten.
Suresh: Ich folgte.
Chathura Praboda: Ja.
Suresh: Meine Familie.
Founder Office: Ich buchstabiere meinen Familiennamen. Ich buchstabiere meinen Familiennamen.
Founder Office: In der Prüfung sollen sie auch etwas buchstabieren.
Founder Office: Ich wohne in Frankfurt, in der Schweizerstraße. Salf die Postleitzahl
Founder Office: sprachen. Ich spreche Spanisch und Englisch und ein Lizenz Deutsch. Meine Muttersprache heißt Spanisch.
Founder Office: Wie lange der Beruf Ich arbeite in einem Büro. Ich habe keinen Beruf. Ich lerne Deutsch.
Founder Office: Meine Hobbys sind Lesen und schwimmen. Ich höre auch gern Musik. Meine Hobbys sind Lesen und schwimmen. Ich höre auch gern Musik.
Founder Office: Ich höre auch gerne Musik weiter. Können Sie sagen, ich wohne zusammen die Fragen stellen und Antworten
Founder Office: mit 3 anderen Personen.
Founder Office: Sie nehmen eine Karte zu einem Thema etc.
Founder Office: Auf der Karte steht Dein Wort.
Founder Office: Sie stellen Ihren Partner, Ihre Partnerin ist.
Founder Office: Was sagen Sie, Was sagt Ihr Partner, Ihre Partnerin.
Founder Office: die die die.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Der.
Suresh: Machen, die
Suresh: Einkaufen.
Founder Office: Einkaufen. Ab. Hier Einkaufen.
Suresh: Ich habe ihn.
Founder Office: Ja, wie lange denn die
Founder Office: ist.
Founder Office: Sie können Fragen kommen: Wo kaufen Sie ein, Die, die die.
Suresh: Die die.
Founder Office: Sie.
Suresh: Eine Woche.
Founder Office: Was kaufen Sie ein.
Founder Office: die, wie oft Sie ja.
Suresh: Die die.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Die ja.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: Ist
Founder Office: auf dem Markt.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe auf dem Markt ein.
Founder Office: Ja, die.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: und.
Founder Office: Im Supermarkt oder auf dem Markt, die die die am.
Suresh: Am Samstag.
Founder Office: Am Samstag
Founder Office: am Samstag. Okay, Die
Founder Office: am Samstag, Samstag
Founder Office: die.
Suresh: Wurde.
Founder Office: Eine.
Suresh: Oder was.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Aha.
Suresh: Aber.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Was weiß ich?
Founder Office: Was.
Suresh: Wenn.
Founder Office: Die
Founder Office: die.
Suresh: Im.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Mogadisch.
Suresh: Ich.
Founder Office: Kennen.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: Die.
Chathura Praboda: Was ist.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Mit.
Founder Office: Die.
Founder Office: Was kaufen Sie am
Founder Office: Was kaufen Sie Am.
Founder Office: Okay, Was kaufen Sie am Samstag ein? Was kaufen Sie am Samstag? Ein.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Founder Office: Gerne ins Adresse.
Founder Office: Die: Was machen Sie am Samstag?
Founder Office: Was kaufen Sie am Samstag? Ein Monat.
Chathura Praboda: Schön.
Founder Office: Wo kaufen Sie am Samstag?
Founder Office: Wo kaufen Sie am Samstag ein, die
Founder Office: mit wem kaufen Sie am Samstag ein?
Founder Office: Okay, die, okay, Was kaufst du am Samstag ein?
Founder Office: Was kaufst du wo, kaufst du am Samstag ein, wo haust du?
Founder Office: Mit wem kaufst du am Samstag ein.
Founder Office: Die, was kaufen Sie?
Founder Office: Ich kaufe
Suresh: Die ja.
Founder Office: Ja, Obst und Gemüse ein.
Founder Office: Okay, Ich kaufe am Samstag Obst und Gemüse.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe am Samstag Obst und Gemüse ein.
Founder Office: die ich kaufe, die.
Founder Office: die ich kaufe, im Suppe Matt
Founder Office: ein. Ich kaufe im Supermarkt ein.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe auf den Markt ein auf dem
Founder Office: Markt ein. Ich kaufe im Supermarkt ein. Ich kaufe auf dem Markt teil.
Founder Office: Mit wem kaufen Sie ein?
Founder Office: Ich kaufe mit meinem Bruder mit meiner Mutter, ein mit meiner Schwester ein.
Founder Office: die ich kaufe, mit meinem Bruder, meiner Mutter, meiner Schwester ein, die die.
Suresh: Aber okay.
Founder Office: Wenn.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Ich ist
Founder Office: die.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Aber.
Founder Office: Die, die Sie am Samstag, Ich brauche die
Founder Office: Gegen 10 Uhr, am Vormittag, am Vormittag, am Nachmittag, am Nachmittag am Abend verloren, die die am Nachmittag ein.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe gegen 10 Uhr, 15 Uhr am Vormittag, am Nachmittag mit dem Alex am Nachmittag, wir haben miteinander
Founder Office: sie.
Founder Office: Was kaufst du am Samstag? Wann kaufst du am Samstag, wo kaufst du am Samstag
Founder Office: Getränke gerne trinken.
Founder Office: und die, die, Wo kaufen Sie Getränkedins Mit Was trinken sie am liebsten?
Founder Office: Wo kaufen Sie Getränke, die
Founder Office: Thema, einkaufen.
Suresh: Vielleicht Fleisch.
Founder Office: Fleisch, die, Okay, Die.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Ja ist.
Suresh: Arme, Reiche.
Founder Office: Die einkaufen Jamaika, bitte gewinnen.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: Die
Founder Office: ja, okay, das Thema ist einkaufen. Das Wort ist Fleisch.
Founder Office: Was ist die Frage
Founder Office: ist ja.
Chathura Praboda: Wie viel kostet das Fleisch.
Founder Office: Okay, Wie viel kostet ein Kilo Fleisch, ein Kilo Fleisch?
Founder Office: Wie viel kostet ein Kilo Fleisch, Ein Kilo Fleisch kostet.
Chathura Praboda: Das.
Founder Office: Ja.
Chathura Praboda: Ja.
Chathura Praboda: 20 Juden.
Founder Office: 20€. Okay.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Founder Office: Die: Wie viel kostet ein Kilo Fleisch, Ein Kilo Fleisch kostet 20€. Okay.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Wie viel? Vielleicht kaufen Sie.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: Die die.
Chathura Praboda: B.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Die.
Founder Office: Wo kaufen Sie Fleisch? Wie oft kaufen sie Fleisch? Wie oft kaufen sie Fleisch?
Founder Office: Wie oft kaufen sie Fleisch, die Ich kaufe Fleisch einmal pro Woche, die
Founder Office: ich kaufe. Fleisch einmal pro Woche.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe Fleisch einmal pro Woche.
Suresh: Ja.
Founder Office: Verdammt zweimal pro Woche.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe Fleisch einmal pro Woche, zweimal pro Woche, wo kaufen Sie Fleisch? Ich kaufe Fleisch im Supermarkt auf dem Markt.
Founder Office: die die
Founder Office: die die.
Chathura Praboda: Nicht.
Founder Office: Die die, wo am liebsten, wo am liebsten die die Okay.
Suresh: Ich
Suresh: am liebsten.
Chathura Praboda: Am liebsten.
Chathura Praboda: wo am liebsten
Chathura Praboda: die.
Suresh: Ist die die.
Chathura Praboda: Ja.
Suresh: Was die die ist, Verbindungen.
Suresh: Die.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Suresh: oder was brauchen Sie
Suresh: ist liebsten, Was kaufen Sie am liebsten?
Suresh: Die
Suresh: die Killardino, die auf dem Markt nehmen, immer im Supermarkt auf dem Markt oder die.
Chathura Praboda: Ja.
Suresh: Die
Suresh: der die.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Suresh: und die.
Suresh: Die.
Chathura Praboda: Eine.
Suresh: Aber.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Suresh: und dann hat er Geneigung.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Die.
Suresh: Die, die ja.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: So.
Suresh: ist, ist
Suresh: die.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Suresh: Ja gar.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Aber.
Suresh: Die.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Suresh: Die
Suresh: so die.
Suresh: die ja die ist.
Chathura Praboda: Ihren.
Suresh: Ne Einwei, Die.
Suresh: die
Suresh: ja
Suresh: vielen Dank.
Suresh: Was soll ich.
Chathura Praboda: Ist.
Founder Office: Einkaufen, ist das Thema, wo am liebsten die.
Founder Office: wo am liebsten.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Wo kaufen sie am liebsten ein.
Founder Office: Sehr gut. Wo kaufen Sie am liebsten ein? Wo kaufen sie am liebsten?
Founder Office: Ich.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ein.
Founder Office: Die Suppe macht.
Founder Office: 1.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe im Supermarkt Sorry.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe am liebsten im Supermarkt ein. Am liebsten.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe am liebsten im Supermarkt ein.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe am liebsten im Supermarkt einkaufen.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Macht.
Founder Office: Die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Kaufen sie auf dem Markt ein.
Founder Office: Die, die ja die.
Suresh: Nur.
Founder Office: Was kaufen Sie auf dem Markt.
Suresh: Wir machen.
Founder Office: Ja, was kaufen Sie auf dem Markt ein, nur der Marketing gar nicht.
Founder Office: Wann kaufen Sie auf dem Markt ein.
Founder Office: wie lang die mit wem kaufen sie?
Founder Office: Au?
Founder Office: Wem mag sein die?
Founder Office: Was kaufen Sie auf dem Marktteil? Wann kaufen Sie auf dem Markt teil. Mit wem kaufen Sie auf dem Markt teil?
Founder Office: Ich kaufe Obst und Gemüse. Ich kaufe Fleisch ein. Ich kaufe, wann kaufen Sie auf dem Markt teil. Wann.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe am Wochenende.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: Wochenende auf dem Markt sein, am Samstag, am Sonntag am abend am Nachmittag
Founder Office: die.
Suresh: Okay, Wir.
Founder Office: Die
Founder Office: ich kaufe, mit meiner Mutter ein. Ich kaufe mit meiner Schwester ein. Ich kaufe mit meinem Bruder ein, mit Sachen, die eine gut gelehrt.
Suresh: Das.
Founder Office: Ja die.
Suresh: Ist.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: So konnten sie Gemüse.
Founder Office: Wie oft kaufen Sie Gemüse ein?
Founder Office: Wie oft kaufen Sie geben uns ein.
Suresh: Wie oft kaufen sie.
Founder Office: Sehr gut. Wie oft kaufen sie Getränke ein? Wo kaufen Sie Getränke? Ein.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ja.
Founder Office: Ja, wie oft kaufen sie Schokolade ein? Wo kaufen Sie Schokolade?
Founder Office: Sehr gut.
Founder Office: Die, die ja
Founder Office: der am Nachmittag.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Wir.
Founder Office: Die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ich kaufe am Samstag.
Founder Office: und.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Rühren.
Founder Office: Ich kaufe am Samstag ein. Ich kaufe am Wochenende. Ich kaufe am Abend ein. Ich kaufe am Nachmittag Geil. Ich kaufe am Vormittag Geil ohne.
Suresh: Nein.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Freizeit.
Chathura Praboda: Frau.
Founder Office: Die die.
Suresh: Die.
Founder Office: Die.
Suresh: Nein, nein.
Chathura Praboda: Das.
Founder Office: Die die die die.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Oder.
Founder Office: Die
Founder Office: aber der die.
Suresh: Ist.
Founder Office: Die.
Chathura Praboda: Wir.
Chathura Praboda: Ja.
Founder Office: Die.
Chathura Praboda: Die.
Founder Office: Die
Founder Office: gute Nacht.